the man in this footage is facing life
in prison after he killed a career
criminal attempting to mug him the
kicker the government agrees the
shooting was justified
the Queen's da brought several charges
against Charles foner after cops found
some unlicensed guns in his apartment he
might serve decades behind bars for
owning firearms that didn't have the
proper stamp of approval from
bureaucrats even though he used his
weapon in self-defense that's
considerably more time than his
assailant would have gotten gun
licensing schemes criminalized otherwise
law-abiding gun owners and
disproportionately impact poor people of
color in New York City where black
people are about 20 to 25 percent of the
population they made up almost 70
percent of gun possession arrests over
the last decade not everyone can afford
to pay the fees and jump through the
Hoops to get permission for their
firearms which a lot of folks in high
climb areas need to protect themselves
there are many people whose names you'll
never hear whose only violent felony was
breaking Licensing Laws no one should be
punished for exercising a constitutional
right